uh so this is inspired by go longhorns
five there's a draft of all players from
any era in their prime of course
32 teams 12 rounds with free agency to
follow
to fill out rosters you have the first
overall pick who do you choose and why
so what we're doing now is we're gonna
begin filling out our teams with our
back and forth draft based on this idea
that they're players in their prime
who are we taking here's the question
for sims to determine whether or not he
gets the first pick
kurt russell had a minor league baseball
career before becoming an actor which
baseball movie screen screenplay
was originally written with him
in mind wow
gosh it can't be major league that
certainly doesn't seem like that would
be i'm gonna say major league i'm gonna
go with that
the natural what is it no it can't be
that i thought it was the natural you
know what
the first when i saw the question the
first thing i thought of was a league of
their own i could have seen him being
the manager
oh right women's team in a league of
their own instead of tom hanks but
but bull durham okay um all right i get
the first pick
good i don't want the first pick um
i'll take it well if i no i'm taking it
i'm taking it you're gonna like it
you're gonna like it
it's a guy you're jealous of give me tom
brady i mean
you give me give me i want i want
everything that goes with the tom brady
experience on my team
because he's gonna be the leader to
bring all these guys together he's gonna
be the quarterback of the team
he's shown that he knows how to put the
pelts on the wall over and over again
i ultimately want to win championships i
like guys who win championships i'll
take tom brady okay all right that's
that's good for you i mean it's hard to
argue that
it's hard to argue uh i understand it
um you know of course i think there's
better quarterbacks out there
all right so oh i know and i know which
one you're gonna take no i'm not
i'm not going there listen there'll be a
great quarterback in round two at pick
33. i'm not worried about it there's
more than 32 great quarterbacks for us
to win a super bowl with this great team
i'm not starting off with the
quarterback
i'm going right away i'm going lt i'm
going lawrence taylor i'm going to the
defense i'm going to go to a special
guy that plays like three different
positions in one defense and outside
linebacker
can drop back into pass coverage could
play stand-up middle linebacker i mean
whatever it is freak of nature
i mean going to change the way the
offense plays you
i mean look at this oh yeah try to cut
block him good luck
ron jaworski i mean yeah oh hey jay
schroeder i mean
he and he invented like the two tight
end set
because of him he changed the way
offensive lines had a block
because as my dad would always explain
in those days the running back blocked
the linebackers the big people blocked
the big people
well they found out in a hurry that you
couldn't let block that guy with a
running back so you had to put a big big
person on him so i'm gonna go lt to
start it off
all right uh th this is painful to me
because i want to say walter payton next
but i got to take barry sanders i think
you know in his prime barry sanders was
the best running back that ever played
so give me barry sanders no question
it's hard cause
i i i admired walter payton uh even as a
as a
vikings fan in my youth and i thought he
was the best running back ever at the
time but barry sanders and he left a lot
on the table he retired
when he still had gas in the tank but uh
you know the moves
the stop the start the broken ankles
just incredible and he he's that guy
remember he would
he would maybe he would maybe get caught
and lose three yards
or just you know go for it he didn't get
him behind the line of scrimmage he was
gone
yeah no the the biggest big play running
back we've ever seen in the history of
football you're right there could have
been
three runs in a row for one yard minus
one and minus two
but then the next run was break seven
ankles and
you know turn on the afterburners and
outrun everybody for a 60-yard touchdown
that's what's amazing
it's i mean all the long touchdown runs
he had
for a guy that's supposed to be like
quick and accelerate and all that he had
great long speed
um amazing amazing football player i'm
not mad at you there all right
i think here i'm um
oh i'm not sure what i'm gonna go here
i'm gonna go with jerry rice here
i am i'm gonna go with jerry rice i'm
gonna get a wide receiver that's just
got no weakness it can run every route
in the world can do
things yards after catch anything like
that
i mean rice to me is just you can't miss
with him at the wide receiver position
he can do it all i mean he can run the
wes
welker short routes at a really high
level and as you see here he can run
pipe run by people and i grew up
you know watching them run by people uh
whether it's deep speed or whatever else
i mean the ultimate professional
gonna know how to play read coverages
look at that
bouncing off carl mecklenburger and
everybody else i mean
phenomenal phenomenal football player i
think that was steve atwater he bounced
off of
okay and look i i wrestled with which
receiver i'd want first but now that
you've taken one i'm to go ahead and
wait for a while to take mine
i have yet to address the defense and
uh you you've got the greatest pass
rusher of all time and lawrence taylor
i'll take the greatest corner of all
time and dion sanders yes
i know that the ball isn't going to be
thrown
to half of the field ever if you have
dion in his prime and you put him on
punt return duty
you're good to go maybe he plays a
little offense too in his prime
prime time in his prime i'm surprised he
lasted as long as he did yeah he would
have been coming up really quick for me
there's no doubt about that um i mean
yeah he's a great first pick
there's nobody ever played man-to-man
coverage better than deion sanders and
like when you draft him
of course it gives you a lot of leeway
like we've talked about with great
corners and football right now to do
other things you know with the rest of
the defense you don't necessarily have
to be perfect wait this guy locks this
down and now we can find a lot of
different ways to stop
stop all the other uh other stuff there
so uh i'm i'm with you there i think he
would have been my next pick for sure
okay i'm stuck here
i really am um
man i'm thinking about doing something
crazy here i really am
i'm going quarterback here i'm going
quarterback and i'm just going to tell
you
i'm almost in the mold of i'm actually
contemplating whether to go mahomes
or aaron rodgers i don't know which one
i want to go with
i know mahomes isn't in his prime yet
that's the thing that's where i want to
pick him because i want to go like
you know i think six eight years from
now we're gonna look back at it and go
we've never seen a prime anything like
this guy's prime
i'm gonna go with the homes i am i'm
gonna go with it i know
i can't believe i'm doing that to my oh
aaron rodgers but i'm a little bit
picking on the guy of like what i'm
expecting here in the future too
and i just contin i think it's going to
continue to be awesome and awesomer
you know he's got a great way about him
you talked about brady and what he can
do for the locker room and lead and all
those type of stuff
mahomes has a lot of those qualities too
there's no doubt he's young of course
still
and still developing some of that stuff
but man it's hard
i i i we've never seen anybody come into
the league and take the league by storm
like patrick mahomes has this is a
pretty special story and
you know he does have the talent uh to
be the greatest
the greatest quarterback to ever live
there's no doubt
hey i mean think about it but for a coin
flip in overtime he could possibly be
working on three straight super bowls in
three years
as a starter yeah that's right i mean
that's it
and and and if they had decided
uh to go with him as a rookie who knows
who knows
yeah in a row right so uh and and again
the prime's not there yet so
uh he's only gonna get better presumably
uh okay
um i gotta have somebody block i know
tommy i know i gotta have i gotta go
with anthony munoz
lt is i gotta go i gotta put anthony i
gotta put anthony
i gotta put anthony munoz and to help
yeah uh to
to keep lawrence taylor from getting
after tom brady although you know what
bring bring lt around the side tom brady
can deal with the pressure around the
side it's pressure up the middle it's a
problem see you should have taken aaron
donald instead of lawrence taylor
so uh either way i'll take anthony munoz
to slow down lawrence taylor aaron
donald is on my list though for sure
i mean to me he is one of the greatest
he's on mine too yeah he's one of the
greatest defensive players ever uh yeah
so
he might be coming up here and sapp's
going to text
he's on my list too actually warren sapp
john randall there are other defensive
tackles that are on my list here
i mean hey listen anthony moon is lt i
mean uh
eat your eat your popcorn you know emoji
right there
but 10 out of 10 who you saying who's
going to win that battle 10 times they
go out against each other i know
seven to lt oh he's going seven to lt
okay yeah i'm gonna give him the edge
too i'm gonna go
six six to four or something like that
he's gonna he's gonna go 10 out of 10 on
everybody else matt casey
at least anthony munoz has a chance
oh that's funny all right well you know
what i'm going to make you readjust your
offensive line thoughts because
he's still on the board and this might
arguably be the best defensive player in
the history of football
reggie white i'm gonna go with reggie
white fine hey one thing i know is if
you pressure tom brady with the front
four he's not very good
we got a good two right now i know that
so i'll go with reggie
i mean to me reggie is definitely the
greatest
down lineman in the history of football
defensively like put your hand on the
ground you know lt's an outside
linebacker
but for that guy man reggie white d
tackle defense and unbelievable power
but
speed of a really special pass rusher at
320 pounds and
used to scare me when he would go after
my dad you know twice a year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports